cbs news has obtained video of an
american teenager who recently escaped
the isis stronghold of raqqa syria
militias backed by the united states are
close to driving isis out of the city
ollie williams in northern syria has the
story of this young civilian
who claims she was forced to go there
when she was just 10 years old
ali good morning good morning the 15
year old girl was captured on video
just after escaping isis territory in
raqqa with a group of other women
she is a devout muslim but says she
hated living under isis
i'm from kansas
i've been in syria for five years
she survived life in the so-called isis
capital
and its bombardment by u.s airstrikes
witnessing things no child should ever
have to see
there was the dead body everywhere you
walk if you see a
bombed building you smell the smells of
the you know
the bodies she says she was brought to
syria against her will
by her father we were afraid of him we
didn't trust him
we were just you know quiet shut up
sit down you're in your house you have
nothing to say
be glad your head isn't chopped up her
father was later killed she says
leaving her to fend for herself she
married a syrian man
who she says was also killed by an
airstrike and reveals
she's now six months pregnant i feel
ready
i feel ready for what life wants to
throw at me because she's still a minor
we're not revealing her identity
this blog previously written by her
mother shows the girl in happier times
and what looks like a normal american
family
she thinks her mother is still in the
u.s
hi mom please
if you see this video please
contact me now she says she wants to be
reunited with what's left of her family
i still have hope to go to school hope
to be a normal
person hope to be a mother
to my child there's a lot of stories
that
i could tell you
five years and with isis you would see a
lot
the girl was last seen in the custody of
u.s backed syrian forces
we do not know if she's been handed over
to the u.s authorities
gail thank you very much holly williams
reporting
it's one of those things you hope
somehow her mother sees her that somehow
they can get back together it's
heartbreaking
incredibly sad story and great reporting
by the whole team over there very good
reporting